we're here to teach you a lesson
lesson learned
ping toca a mighty warrior ruler of this
lands but there's one thing missing in
his life bang - oh yeah there's a
brownie and what they don't know is how
you don't [ __ ] with bronies my little
pony is the one that watch friendship
will be in a penny hey
we finally arrived to another town I
hope they will greet me politely Jesus
Christ what happened I know my pony
shout no the legends are true
the trains the trains anything but the
tray
- chicken
[ __ ] sake what are you even doing here
land crab land crabs stop
I didn't ask much sake the [ __ ]
trains that was a long travel I hope the
next time will be nicer I hope we can
find one town that accept us for who we
are why will no one except us no they
killed they killed horse oh my god what
Stephanie you kill horsey
what's that noise
what is that sound the legends are true
Thomas anything but Thomas the Train
Jesus Christ why does everyone hate
brown eggs kill Thomas I think I killed
one if it bleeds you can kill it it
doesn't bleed though but but I did kill
it I need to call in my cousin's
trainers MO
I don't know what I'm doing we need to
escape we need to escape when we can
[ __ ] sake they're still after us down
this waterfall we can't outrun them no
matter how fast we are we'll never be
able to escape but wait what's happening
I'm evolving I'm evolving to a sanic
ancestors are true
what are you going to do sanic run sanic
run for your life
sonogram for many years sanic found
another city but he knew his kind wasn't
welcome here either
you needed a disguise IKEA's born
hailing from the northern lands of
sweden the ikea bow and take their name
from the endless home furnishing
labyrinth but he knows by looking at his
hands it was still a brony at heart
and nothing could change dan not even
the children wanted to play with him
wanna play tag [ __ ] it would have at
that moment bank token realized he
needed to purge these lands from the non
brony even the bronies
oh no they found me again Thomas no how
did you know it was me my only way out
of this the bow of the brony yes oh I
killed one it was a test moment
Thomas had killed all the trains it
realized only had to do was to be
himself all along
but it was also then it hit him
Thomas was a train all along